[Music]
I'm Keith Cohen I'm the owner of all
Washington's bakery we are in one of New
York City's oldest and most iconic food
establishments and this is how we make
our croissants I want to take this
opportunity to introduce Yusef he is
croissant master here in our giant mixer
we're gonna add flour milk salt sugar
milk powder
he adds milk powder because it adds it's
dehydrated so it's it acts more as a
solid when we first met you so we taste
this croissant so when you look at it
and you taste it you don't change his
recipe yeast water ice water is very
important especially during the summer
it brings the mixed temperature down so
you don't want too hot of the dough
because what's gonna happen is a the
dough is gonna prove but more
importantly your butter is gonna start
to break down and finally butter we
source our butter from France every
country has their own terroir because
butter is so integral to the taste of
the croissant we felt it necessary once
the dough is mixed we want to be able to
pull it out and chunk it into six kilo
increments much like a lot what we do
here there's a resting period pre shape
gives strength so one of the critical
things almost like bread is you have to
give strength to your dough in order to
pre shape it you want to make sure
you're gentle with the dough you want to
fold it under itself without damaging it
too much that dough has to have that
stretch in that shine when we talk about
letting the dough proof or rest you'll
also see about a doubling in the size of
the volume you're gonna punch the dough
down after it's doubled in size it's
gonna give it a time to deflate you'll
take a little bit out of the gas it will
tighten up on you a little bit and it'll
be ready for the freezing process during
the freezing process because we're not
doing blast freezing the dough is still
fermenting which is also very important
one of the keys to croissants are
there's not only butter in the dough
but there's butter that gets laminated
in
the dough so you're putting dough with
butter sandwich and then you are passing
it through a sheeter which stretches out
the dough and makes it a little bit
thinner again what you're looking for is
that layered effect the way you are able
to do that is through folding the dough
again and then turning it so it becomes
exponential don't hold me to my math but
once you have four layers your next set
you will probably have somewhere around
16 layers and the sign of a good
croissant is you should be able to see
the laminates once it's finalized
sheeting it's now ready for cutting so
we have to have a ten-foot table now so
we can lay out the entire sheet and
again it is about the timing so we able
to cut it quickly after it gets cut into
strips it now has to be cut on the angle
so you can get that beautiful triangle
the shape of a croissants aren't
crescent they are oblong youssef has
developed I believe it's somewhat his
own technique of taking the croissant
and giving a little bit of a stretch and
with each little stretch or each little
pat that you see it does it gives a
little bit extra so you get an extra
roll and at the same time it gives it a
little bit more strength so in addition
to our regular croissant we do a pan of
Chocolat it's a little bit easier to
roll but again there's a technique the
way we use the chocolate batons and
making sure that it's rolled tight
enough so they don't melt when they're
baked once again here temperature is
working against us once we're done
rolling the particular sheet whether
it's a plain croissant or a pan or
Chocolat we're going to put it right
back in the freezer the proofing stage
is a highly critical stage for
croissants things they get over proofed
we could have a tendency to collapse in
the oven and or one of the key
indicators is the butter coming out of
the product the egg wash gives a nice
shine to it it's more aesthetics we bake
our croissants off at 350 degrees in a
convection oven
what's happening now now that the heat
is starting to bake the croissant again
you are getting some ovens bring to it
you're developing that beautiful
honeycomb interior the butter is
starting to melt throughout the product
not completely out of the pod
but into the product itself and again
through the Maillard reaction you're
getting a beautiful crisp crust to it
best time to enjoy a croissant is when
it's room temperature you're allowing
the butter to get reabsorbed into it and
allow some of the gas to escape it's
very important to achieve all your full
flavors after the product reaches room
temperature when you cut it open you'll
see this beautiful honeycomb interior
and that is really one of the keys to a
great croissant on a well baked
croissant you should have a beautiful
crackle to the crust and you should have
a soft and supple interior and the
butter if it's high quality should taste
very very neutral to me croissants are
the epitome of French baking and that is
how croissants amazing
[Music]